okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
and i see there's a bunch of questions
here saved up from
previous times
um let me see there's a question here
from
alexander asking about experimenting
with multi-way hypergraphs and so on
and physics as a hobbyist computational
explorer
um well let's see so
so what he's referring to there is uh
all the things that we've been working
on in this project
to find the fundamental theory of
physics um
and uh we're in which we've been having
just
magnificent success over the last uh um
um the uh
um excuse me um
i wish we've we've had uh kind of
magnificent success over the last year
or so
and um there's a question of what uh
uh how can how can one sort of get
involved in that we've been
live streaming a bunch of our internal
uh
working sessions and so on so you can
kind of see
see what's being done in terms of doing
it yourself
the full formalism of our physics
project is
a little bit daunting in a sense
anything that is going to be
operating at a level so far below what
we experienced so far below sort of our
ordinary notions of space and time
it's sort of inevitable that that's
going to be a bit abstract
and a little bit hard to hard to kind of
wrap one's arms around
so you can perfectly well run
the wolfram language code that
makes hyper graphs which are our
representation of the content of space
the content of the universe
and updates them and so on but it may be
a little hard to understand what's going
on
um it's it's hard for us to understand
what's going on we it's sort of the
upper limit
of our kind of both computer in
computer experiment intuition and
mathematical prowess
to understand what's going on so
what i would say if you want to kind of
go in this direction
the best thing to do is to start getting
intuition about how
computational systems work because the
computational systems we think
underlie actual physics in our universe
are in a sense more abstract
than the ones that are easy for one to
get one's one's one
brain around so to speak but the ones
that
are they're ones that are uh
sort of easy for us to understand
roughly what how the thing is set up
even if it's difficult to understand
what it does the ones that we're using
for physics are even hard for us to
understand how they're set up
so i would say my favorite type of
systems to study are cellular automata
where you just have a line of cells each
one is black or white
and then in a series of steps you just
update the color of each cell
depending on the color of the cell above
it and to its left and right
and by setting up rules like that
you end up finding and this was my big
surprise in the early 1980s
that even when the rule is very simple
and even when you started off from just
something like one black cell
in the middle of an array of white cells
you can end up with these very
complicated patterns of behavior
and so a good place to start is by just
experimenting with those kinds of things
and that's trivial to do a morphing
language there's a just a function
called
cellular automaton that lets you do that
and i think
a good place to start is just explore
some versions
of cellular automata that perhaps have
been explored before perhaps haven't
been explored before
what's amazing about the sort of
computational universe of possible
programs is
it's an infinite collection of possible
programs and even rather simple programs
we've only got a tiny distance in
exploring what they do
so it's rather easy to kind of start
seeing things that people haven't seen
before the the difference between a
cellular automaton and the kind of thing
we're using for our models of physics
is in a cellular automaton there's a
rigid array of cells
kind of laid out in space and
progressing with time
whereas in our models of physics once
just dealing with these sort of points
that exist
and these connections between points and
there's no pre-existing notion
of space and there's also in a sense no
pre-existing notion of time
in a cellular automaton every cell is
getting updated
in step at each time step
whereas in our models of physics it's
like all these different places in the
universe
can get updated separately and that's
what leads to these kind of multi-way
graphs that correspond to different
parts of history
leads to quantum mechanics things like
that so i would i would start with
cellular automata that's where i started
40 years ago that's how i kind of built
up the intuition to be able to try and
do these things in our physics project
um then once you have some intuition for
that and you have some familiarity
with how to use kind of the
computational tools and visualization
and so on
for that then uh there's a on the web
and our wolfram physics.org website
there's a tutorial about how to use the
computational tools that we have for
studying the physics project
that's probably the next place to jump
to or possibly the technical
introduction to our project
that i wrote last year is a is a long
and fairly
uh fairly step-by-step description of
how these kind of models of physics work
let's see there's a question here
um from just nueces
how could one convince the scientific
community that they have inadvertently
accepted a false result
when the bug when the mistake is subtle
that is a good question and very
pertinent to these pandemic times
i mean many things that people have
believed
in this pandemic have turned out to be
not quite right
and some of those things come from areas
of science where people should have
known better
and some come from areas of science
where one doesn't yet know
so for example one example
uh where i don't know how many people in
the scientific community really claimed
this
it's a very weird claim the claim oh you
should wear a mask
even if you're outside this claim is
bizarre
because if you work out you know how
much
uh if if you're in a room there are
there can be little virus particles that
are on droplets and so on that can float
around the room and can even
stay airborne in the room for hours
potentially if there's not much airflow
but if you're outside what you have
the little piece of air that is near you
is mixing with the whole atmosphere of
the earth
which is just completely huge and it has
the feature that
the um uh the the the
the um uh concentration of virus
just goes way down incredibly quickly
because it's just carried around sort of
randomly in the atmosphere of the earth
so of course if you're standing right
next to somebody and you're
you're breathing at each other then it's
a different story but as soon as you're
kind of
out not in a situation where you're
specifically concentrating
um kind of uh water droplets or whatever
else
then you're in a situation where you're
mixing with the whole atmosphere
and it's the the number of
of trillions and trillions of
factors that are involved in kind of the
dilution
of anything it's just huge and it makes
absolutely no sense
to say oh i'm going to get a virus
particle
uh and one virus particle is not going
to make you sick um
from this vast reservoir of air that is
the earth's atmosphere
so i'm not sure how many sort of
scientifically oriented people are
really claiming you should wear a mask
outside i think that that's a
that's more of a kind of a a public
presentation type of thing
you know wear a mask in solidarity with
people who
are wearing masks in other places and so
on the whole question of wearing masks
is a complicated one
where certainly i thought gosh it's an
obviously good idea
maybe it's a good idea for you uh for
yourself oh i shouldn't be infected
maybe it's a good idea for other people
oh if i'm infected i shouldn't uh
spread my infection to other people
turns out the story is a bit
more complicated because in a sense
you know you breathe out the air that
you breathe out has to go
somewhere it's not like the air doesn't
get anywhere
and so the question is you know does it
sort of split out the sides of the mask
now if you wear one of these
very medical grade very you know
contoured to your face type masks then
yes you can make sure that the air you
breathe out is really going through the
mask
to get to the outside world but that's
more difficult to achieve
than one might initially have thought so
again it's something where you know
people would say scientifically and even
i was
thinking this scientifically it makes
sense to wear masks it's not so obvious
that that is as true as one thought it
was
um but figuring out what's actually true
is is quite difficult
um i think that the other uh
other types of things well here's an
example of one that's
that's almost a a weird one a really
weird one
um a recent thing which is the idea
that you should you have an event going
on and you have people
who have gotten vaccines for the
for the virus or maybe have had the
virus since i've developed immunity for
the virus
you say let's make two sections of our
uh you know stadium or something the
vaccinated section and the unvaccinated
section
this is just bonkers
i think i mean in the sense that as a as
a matter of oh you're trying to push
people to get vaccinated well maybe
that's a kind of a way to control people
i think that's a kind of a obnoxious
thing
to to to do but what the thing to
realize is
the whole idea of herd immunity that is
the virus okay how does a virus work a
virus
exists by taking over your cells
and using the apparatus of your cells to
make copies of itself
so that the virus can then spread if the
virus
simply can't continue to exist unless it
can find another host to infect
if it infects you and you develop an
immune response
and you basically kill all the cells
that have virus in them
the viruses you the virus lost out it
isn't making it from you
so the only way it can continue to
survive is by jumping to another host
and uh continuing to replicate in that
host cells
and i think that the um uh that then
so in order for that to happen that has
to be the case the virus
in sort of can actually make this kind
of chain reaction where it goes from you
to two people from two people to each to
two more people so that's four people
then to eight people or whatever it is
it has to be able to
get from person to person and in kind of
the the standard theory of epidemiology
there's a a quantity the r value it's
usually called
which is basically how many people does
a given person infect
now they only get to infect them when
they're actually when they've actually
got lots of virus in them and they're
actually
uh sort of sick and um with maybe a few
little little
things around the edges of that but
that's more or less true by the time the
virus has been sort of
uh you know crushed out of that person
there's no virus to go and infect
anybody else
so then so in order for the thing to
survive it's got to jump from host to
hostiles person to person to person
if the set of people who are susceptible
to the virus is dilute enough
because everybody's had it or they or
their or they've been vaccinated
then the the virus just can't make it it
can't it can't
um uh it can't jump to enough new hosts
to be able to to survive and grow in
number
so that's in a sense what you achieve if
you have a collection of people where
a large fraction of them have been
vaccinated then even if somebody has the
virus it's like okay the virus jumps to
another person oops that person's been
vaccinated
the virus doesn't make it there uh and
then and then it's gone
then then it can't jump to somewhere
else so in a sense the
the operation of kind of the herd
immunity idea
which is the way that viruses end i mean
when viruses like flu viruses
other coronaviruses and so on infect
humans
what happens is they infect a bunch of
humans and sometimes they infect
billions of humans around the planet
but what happens is eventually enough
people get to be immune to those viruses
that the viruses just can't find enough
new hosts
to infect and the viruses effectively
die out or close to die out
there's usually a small sort of there's
small pockets of the virus that get left
over which
which is why they can kind of reappear
in a subsequent season and things like
this
but i think that the um uh so you know
an idea of i'm not sure this is really
so much of a science idea
of let's you know if you separate the
vaccinated and unvaccinated people so
you actually have people
where there where you have a group of
people where effectively the r value is
still
large then those people will actually
get sick
if there's virus going around if you put
those people
in a dilute way among people who are
vaccinated who've had the virus
nobody's going to get sick because the
virus just can't make it
through that through that kind of forest
of um
of unfriendly hosts so to speak i think
the um another thing which is um
oh gosh there's so many things that have
gone wrong in this in this
pandemic i think that the the one
interesting feature perhaps
is that if one's interested in virology
epidemiology immunology
probably the amount of data collected in
the last year
is probably uh might even be larger than
the whole hundred years
before it in terms of of what we now
know so a good example
of um when we test we do
tests for uh uh you know
covered tests the testing for the amount
of
virus in your nose or whatever else that
testing is done
using a technique called pcr maybe i can
explain how pcr works
um where what one's doing is okay so how
does it work
you get this sample of stuff from your
nose or whatever
and what you're trying to do is you're
trying to find are there little pieces
of dna
rna actually that um are
are pieces that come from the virus as
opposed to pieces that come from you so
so we have six billion base pairs
that represents the program for each of
us that's the that's the size of the
genome for a human
this virus has about 29 000 base pairs
that represent the program for it
and the question is if you see a little
fragment a little
little piece of that sequence the
program is the sequence of
base pairs which you can usually
represent as letters a t
c g and so on so you'll see a t t t c
g g a t t whatever you see some sequence
of letters
the question is is that sequence of
letters a piece of the program for us
or is it a piece of the program for the
virus and what one's doing in those
tests
is to try and identify are there is the
stuff that's in your nose
little fragments of things whose
programs are
the programs for for the virus and
typically one will be looking for pieces
of the virus like it's
its most obnoxious element is its
so-called spike protein
but there's also things like it's capsid
which is the the sort of container
of the of the rna for the virus and the
these
these have characteristic sort of little
programs that make those things and so
what you're doing
is you're trying to identify do you have
uh something
in your nose let's say that is a program
from the virus as opposed to just a
program for the cells
in your nose so a program for human
versus a program for
virus so how do you tell that
well use a technique called pcr pcr
stands for polymerase chain reaction
so what you do is you take the cells
take the stuff you've got
you kind of break it down and you break
out little pieces of the middle
molecules
and some of those molecules will be rna
for example um and
which is these these pieces of this
program that sequences the the molecule
consists of a sequence
of different so-called bases these
different sections that contain
a few tens of atoms each and there are
four kinds of
these bases four kinds of lumps of tens
of atoms
and you're looking at what that sequence
uh aligned on the sort of backbone of
the molecule what that sequence is
okay so pcr uses the idea that this
thing called polymerase
is the thing that will cause one to
essentially replicate
copies of whatever the program
was on some fragment of rna and
the the the idea of of pcr is
you go through a series of cycles and at
every cycle what is a cycle a cycle is
you squirt chemicals in you heat the
thing up
and you keep doing that and you cycle
through multiple cycles every cycle
you're i think doubling the number of
copies of the rna that you have
okay so that means whatever rna is there
you're
pcring it up as people usually say
you're saying um for this and you you
have a particular template so you're
saying
does this particular does this
particular sequence
occur here if it does double the number
of that sequence that occurs
and you keep doing that in a series of
cycles and so
what in order to tell whether you have
this virus you just keep doing it a
bunch of times
and then you see by the time you've done
it let's say 40 times
that will be 2 to the 40th amplification
of
the number of actual pieces of rna that
are there
and so that means that what started is
just like oh there was just one or two
pieces of rna and that sample that you
got
out will end up being this huge amount
of that viral rna
which is then easy to detect okay so one
of the things that happened
in this whole pandemic story
is this question of the cycle count for
pcr
that is the number of doublings that you
got
in sampling whether there was a virus
there or not
and so the question is how many
uh how many doublings is the right
doubling to use
because if there's just tons of virus in
your nose
you don't need to use very many
doublings and you'll immediately be able
to detect the presence of virus
on the other hand if there was just one
little tiny piece
of you know viral rna that was left over
in your nose
which is not probably going to do you
much harm but just happen to be hanging
out there
and you use a huge number of cycles then
you'll say oh
that person is you know has the virus in
them so it's a sort of a big debate and
usually i think 25 cycles
it's 2 to the 25 amplification factor
um 25 cycles pretty common thing for
people to use for various kinds of pcr
tests
but for various reasons that are in some
sense a little bit obscure to me at
least
a lot of places started using you know
40 cycle pcr
and so on so what does that do well that
means that
that for example the you know
just a little piece of virus that got
left over let's say
let's say you you got the thing it
lodged in your nose and then it ends up
in the sample
it hasn't actually made you sick it
hasn't actually really started
replicating in your body
but it somehow was was sort of stuck
there um then it winds up in this test
where you're amplifying 40 you know
40 fold amplification 2 to the 40th
amplification
it ends up like oh yes that you know
you've got a virus
um you know this is this is all bad so i
think one of the things that's super
confusing
is that the people who
were genuinely sick with a virus where
that was detected with a small pcr
cycle count that people were maybe they
had been sick
three months earlier and there were
little fragments of the virus that were
left over
maybe they just had a little virus that
landed on their nose and their immune
system was going to
rebuff it anyway that were then tagged
as being
you know as being sick in that way so
this is a very confusing thing
and unfortunately in a lot of places uh
well i think the cycle counts in most
places
were in some sense the machines that do
these tests do record the cycle count
whether that data will actually emerge
at any point is not clear
because it's quite possibly the case in
terms of how this works
you know i had always taken the point of
view you either get a virus or you don't
you're either sick or you're not the
virus either
gets to the point where it's replicating
in your body and just making more and
more and more millions billions of
copies of itself
and it's giving you all these symptoms
and so on or your immune system is just
squashing it and and killing off uh all
those little
all the cells that get infected with the
virus and it just never has a chance to
take
take root it's probably the case and
this
question you know what the science
community is going to
eventually figure out it's probably the
case that there's an intermediate story
that in fact at you know that one is
often getting
some amount of virus that makes one not
really sick but sick enough that one's
immune system starts going into action
and saying let's get rid of this virus
and by the way that's not necessarily a
bad thing because if it's a
subclinical that is not visibly
sick infection so to speak then
quite possibly all that happens is oh
you get some of this virus okay
your immune system says okay we better
stop fighting off this virus now let's
get primed
so if we ever get more of this virus
we're ready to go
and we can immediately rebuff the thing
and um
and get rid of it so it could very well
be the case that the typical way that we
operate
in the sort of our immune system has
evolved to operate
is that we are expecting to get exposed
to just a little bit of lots and lots of
viruses
and we gradually build up immunity
through those little exposures
and only sometimes does the virus manage
we get enough of it
or our immune immune system is is too
naive
about how to fight it that the virus
ends up replicating enough to actually
make us sick
you know one of the things that i've
been curious about our immune system has
the ability to fight off about 100
billion
different kinds of sort of patterns of
of things like viruses and so on of of
antigens of of uh
things we don't want to have in us and
and that's in
the that that's enough that sort of in a
sense each antigen is represented to our
immune system
by a sequence of these base pairs of of
what's in its genome
and so this is saying we're recognizing
a hundred billion different things
that we recognize are things that
shouldn't be us
and that will cover any possible thing
that isn't us
will be at least in some approximation
covered by that number of
possible sort of antibodies that we can
form or
or versions of the thing called t cell
receptor that we can produce
but so a question that i think we still
don't know the answer to
in in a typical person you know you've
been around for a few
few years and you've gotten you know
exposure to some viruses
and bacteria things like this how many
of those hundred billion
possible antibodies and so on that you
might be forming
how many of them have you ever used to
mount a defense
and you know is it 10 is it 100 is it a
thousand is it a million
i don't think we really know and that's
an important thing to know because it
kind of affects
uh things like oh questions like you
know if you had another coronavirus
before so for example
a a common theory now again one of these
ones which is all steeped in kind of a
mixture of science and policy and
politics and so on
is you know one reason why the pacific
rim countries
didn't have as many infections as some
other countries in the world
is because there was pre-existing
immunity in those countries because
the sars one virus from what was it 10
15 years ago
had come through and and and uh infected
a lot of people in those countries
and it could be the case that the immune
system that this hundred billion
you know possible antibodies that
there's enough fuzziness
in a particular antibody that's produced
um
that the one from the sars one that
being immune to sars one
is kind of close enough to make you at
least somewhat immune
to the the sars ii covid uh
uh virus so anyway i think that's some
um these are these are things now you
know
the pandemic is a particularly bad case
of
what is believed scientifically versus
what's actually correct
because almost every move that's made in
this pandemic
has enmeshed itself with kind of public
policy and politics and things like this
of look we don't want to tell people
this because then they won't go and get
vaccines and we want people to get
vaccines
so let's not tell them this i don't know
i'm i'm not a big believer
in you know i'm i'm a believer as
perhaps these these very um
live streams might indicate i'm a
believer that people can actually
understand stuff
and that sort of not telling people
things is bad
um and that people are you know i think
there's sort of a there's always a
trade-off because
if you say to people and this is a you
know a trade-off for people who
run governments and things like this is
how much do you tell people
you know in other words if you because
if you start if you tell people a whole
bunch of science
you say everybody should make their own
decision about whether this is a safe
drug or not a safe drug
here's the data it's you know we've got
uh you know a megabyte of data
all go out and figure out whether this
drug is safe and everybody choose for
yourself
well people will be hard-pressed to do
that it's just it's not
something most people are expert at
doing on the other hand you can say
you know that um don't understand this
we're just going to tell you
that even if you've got a vaccine you're
still you still have the potential to be
infectious
which i don't think anybody seriously
scientifically believes but we're just
going to tell you that because
it will affect behavior in a way that
will lead to a better outcome
you know that that's a different model
and it's something where
i think the um uh the question of what
um
uh you know how do you how do you tell
people enough
that they can make the right decisions
um
both for themselves and potentially for
society in general
and and not so much that they're just
confused and don't know what to decide
and potentially end up concluding
something
that's that's in fact completely wacky
so
in any case i think that the um oh gosh
i could just go on and on and on about
the pandemic and about the different
therapies for
which which have been you know where
people have just sort of ignored the
fact that these therapies actually
probably work but
no therapy works all the time for any
disease so saying does it always work et
cetera et cetera et cetera
we could talk about um oh just just all
kinds of things
that um uh it's been a it's been a bad
time
for the interaction of science because
the science really matters
and uh yet people are a kind of um
uh you know it's it's been very
confusing because
for a couple of reasons one of them is
there's science we just don't know
there's a lot that we just don't know
about epidemiology that the spreading of
diseases
about immunology the way that our immune
system attacks disease
there's a lot we do know but there's
also a lot we don't know
and some of the things that have been
really important questions in this
pandemic
are things we just don't happen to know
the answer to some of them i think are
intrinsically hard to answer
for very sort of deep scientific reasons
some of them are just like we just don't
happen to know that
about the immune system you know it's a
it's a famous question
flu tends to be worse than the winter
better in the summer
as in well people more people get sick
in the winter than in the summer
nobody knows why that's been a long time
question
of of is it it's just there are theories
but they're not particularly good
um it's just a big mystery and you know
eventually we'll know the answer to that
but we don't know it yet and and things
like that being
unknown gives one that plays into all of
these uncertainties about
about immunology and so on um
let's see
um
i'm there's a couple of questions about
viruses
uh let me try and address those and then
we'll go on to some other different
topics
motu asks can a virus mutate and
replicate again and again in your body
while the immune system is fighting it
so that every time the immune system
figures out one form and kills it
there's already a new form uh
replicating
a kind of viral cat and mouse game well
in terms of viruses i
well okay let me say there is a case
where that happens in one's body
and it's kind of an unfortunate case
which is with cancer and tumors
because a tumor is basically
something is cells that have a genetic
code that's different from your genetic
code
but similar enough to your genetic code
that usually
the immune system doesn't say hey this
is a bad thing i'm going to get rid of
it
and what can happen is particularly when
you use drugs to attack the the cancer
you'll you'll end up finding out that
you any cancer that has this feature you
kill it off
but as you're getting billions even
trillions of cells
that are progressively replicating um
as at each replication there's a certain
chance
that you get a random mutation that
gives you a different genetics for the
next cell
and the bad thing that can happen is
kind of a sped up version of natural
selection
where the any any tumor cell
that has this characteristic oops the
drug is just going to kill it
but then a tumor cell develops by
mutation that isn't killed by that drug
and so then it's it sort of continues
and it divides
into more cells and it divides and so on
and then that
mutation ends up being one that evolves
and evades those drugs and that's one of
the reasons why
in in in cancer therapy it's very common
to use many drugs
because you're kind of let's let's cut
off this
line of attack this way that the the
thing could mutate
and attack us let's cut off this one and
sometimes kind of a
a modern technique involves let's
predict what it might do next
what mutation it might have next and
let's block that exit
before it even can start in that
direction so the the idea of mutations
progressive mutations in one's body
is kind of the the you know what what
tends to happen in in the case of tumors
now
the the bad feature of tumors is that
our immune systems don't
fight them because they don't because
they're so they're sufficiently similar
to our own genetic setup that they're
not recognized as foreign things one of
the big things that
people try to do is so-called
immunotherapy for cancer it's something
people have been talking about for a
hundred years
um but it's something that is
progressively looks more and more
promising
and in fact the technology that led to
the uh
mrna vaccines that um uh are being used
for
for covid the the um pfizer and madonna
vaccines
that technology was developed for the
purpose of doing immunotherapy for for
tumors
for being able to say here's a tumor
here's the genetics that it has in it
let's invent essentially a vaccine
that specifically attacks things that
have that genetics
and then let's inject that into somebody
and then their immune system
will mount an attack on what is in fact
in that case not a virus
but a tumor cell and so
for example when the vaccines were
developed at the beginning of this
pandemic
what happened is everybody was was kind
of ready there
to just say oh you know somebody has a
tumor with this particular genetic
sequence
let's program up a vaccine a custom
vaccine for that particular genetic
sequence
everybody was ready to do that so when a
virus came in it's like well let's
program up a vaccine
that attacks this virus rather than
attacking
for example the thing that's in a tumor
cell now the question of whether a virus
can mutate
in a person the answer is i think the
mutation rate
is way too low for there to be a a
multiple mutations kind of story
um at best you know you see these trees
of mutations
and it's kind of like the the tree of
life there's progressive mutations of
this virus
and i think oh gosh what is the mutation
rate
um i think it's
like i think in a single person the
average time between mutations
would be years many years and um and and
so
given that it only affects a person for
a small number of days typically
the chance of a mutation among the so so
that means that among the replications
that are happening
for um uh of that virus
in you there are not enough replications
that the chance of an error the transfer
mutation
is small enough that the that while it's
infecting you in particular it's
unlikely
that there'll be more than at most maybe
one mutation and
and more to the more likely one
millionth of a mutation like it has to
infect lots of people before there's a
mutation
um so that's so i don't think
i don't think we'll we'll see that in a
in a single human
uh in the population that's a different
story
let's see uh alex is asking is there
more low-hanging fruit to be collected
in biology it feels like the smartest
people choose to study physics and math
i wonder if more should go into biology
you know that's changed over time as
different fields become more popular
less popular
you know when i was younger physics was
the top dog you know the the best the
the sort of the the best and brightest
type field
it's changed i mean you know it's been
computer science it's been machine
learning it's been neuroscience
and it's been lots of biology um i think
that
the rate of advance in biology in the
last like few decades has been
far you know vastly greater than it has
been in any
other time in history because there are
new methods that have become available
there's new understanding it's really a
kind of golden age for the development
of biology
but biology is hard i mean we're trying
to understand
you know this sort of random series of
events that took place throughout the
three billion years or so of the history
of life on earth
and it's difficult to sort of understand
all of that historically generated stuff
um but i think that uh there's there's a
there's a good number of
of um uh of of uh sort of
people who go into biology now what
tends to happen is one of the questions
about biology
is does one get to use all that physics
and math and computer science
expertise in biology or not because you
know physics is a very theory-based
field
you know we actually do theoretical
physics and we think it it is
we're able to make models of how the
physical world works we're able to make
predictions and so on
in biology there's a tremendous tendency
to just say oh
it's too difficult there can't be a
theory let's just do experiments and
measure what happens
and just say oh this drug is you know 82
percent
um successful we don't really know why
that's just the number
and it comes from an experiment and so i
think one of the things that is
has the potential to happen is really a
flowering of more theoretically oriented
biology i think
the immune system is a great example
that um
uh of um of a place where
i think there's a need for a a sort of a
new theoretical paradigm
uh to understand what's going on in fact
i i have a slight suspicion that some of
the things we've learned from our
physics project
and the kind of paradigm for distributed
computation
that's happened in the physics project
may actually be relevant to
understanding things like the immune
system
um but they're they're a place where it
could do with more physics and math type
thinking
um you know experiments go a great but
at some point you know a million
experiments can't
make up for not understanding the big
picture of what's happening
because you just don't know which
experiment to do you don't have a bigger
theory about what's going on
and um yeah pomenitis is mentioning
paul allen's big neurobiology project
yeah there's a there's a bunch of
projects
to um uh sort of understand the brain
whatever that means that's been a
popular area neuroscience has been a
particularly popular area
um it's not to me uh
so completely clear what some of the
objectives are there
because it's yes there's there's what
we're seeing is
artificial neural networks which were
kind of conceptually
related to our brains work back in the
1940s artificial neural networks that
turn into machine learning
and artificial intelligence and so on a
huge amount has been done with those in
the last decade
and lots of tasks that we used to think
were sort of
humans only like recognizing this is a
bird versus this is an elephant or
something
those used to be very difficult to get a
computer to do they're now
tolerably easy to get a computer to do
at a level
of of uh success that's similar to what
humans can do
and that's something where we've
understood from this kind of
idealization
of things about how brains work but it's
a very much of an idealization
that yes we can do that now the question
is how does it actually work in an
actual brain
and the same principles seem to apply
but the details are somewhat different
and it's a little bit unclear to me
what we will learn from sort of more
detailed understanding about how brains
work i mean maybe we will get
as we did in the case of artificial
neural nets we got sort of a hint
about how we could build a computational
system but it's worth remembering
that that hint took between 1943
and 2011 to really catch on
in other words it took you know a solid
what is it some 70 years or something
to um uh to really uh actually go
from the hint from biology to the
practice of computation
and so it's it's not clear you know if
we learn some particular thing
about some this is a really nifty trick
that brains use
that was learnt from evolution it's
unclear how quickly we can deploy that
in technology for example
and if we want to know things like well
how do we how do we for example connect
to brains you know how do we make a
a direct connection between the
electronics that we have
and brains that's something there's a
bunch of efforts to do that right now
so you've got to remember nerves in our
brain the hundred billion nerve cells in
our brain
they're all operating electrically
they're all a thousand times a second or
something
they're making their little pulse of
electricity
that is the thing that is the actual
stuff that is
what our thoughts are made of so to
speak and so
the thing that one thinks about doing is
can one for example
detect uh from those hundred billion
nerve cells
can you detect sort of individual little
spikes of electrical activity
and record and figure out sort of what
thinking is going on on the basis of
that
our eeg our electroencephalogram our
brain waves
um you know where you just have a 12
leads or something of these big
electrodes connected to your head or
something like that
they are a very very coarse version
of sort of recording that electrical
activity in your brain instead of
recording from individual neurons
they're recording from clumps of
millions or billions of neurons and
they're recording just large scale
features of the electrical activity in
the brain but one of the things that one
would like to do
if one wants to understand sort of more
precisely what's the brain thinking
about
is to record individual uh the activity
of individual nerve cells
and um the uh uh the thing that um
uh so you know in the case of uh the
giant axon of the squid
which is a very big nerve cell it's very
easy to record from a single
nerve cell in that case in a squid in us
humans
it's um uh well it's difficult to get
access to the the brain but
but even so it's quite difficult to
record although possible to record from
single neurons
the thing that's kind of the state of
the art of technology now is a little
array that's like a
like a chip like a microprocessor chip
except that it's something that
you know you have to put inside you put
it sort of on the surface of the brain
and then you can it has an array where
it might record from a thousand
different
neurons that are nearby now you only get
to record on the surface
one of the things that i think is sort
of the test of that technology that i've
been kind of waiting for
since i was a kid is the type by thought
type technology
you know right now if you type something
what's happening your brain is thinking
i'm going to type
an s or something and then you know that
the the signal is being
generated in your brain uh in the end it
ends up
in the motor strip which is a piece of
um a piece of your brain that's about
there i think
um it's what happens is
neurons in the motor strip start
becoming active start producing little
spikes of electricity
and then they transmit those spikes of
electricity to nerves
that go through your spinal cord and
eventually actually end up being the
nerve
that excites the muscle in your finger
and makes you type that key
now you might say oh there's an extra
tenth of a second
that is always messing around of sending
the nerve signal
all the way down your arm and to your
finger and etc etc etc
let's just pick it up right in the motor
strip and let's not have to move any
fingers
you just think about typing an s and um
you can then type the s so
it's been kind of a long running story
back in the 1960s
even before that there were experiments
done on sort of uh actuate by thought so
to speak and was particularly done for
for military pilots for example where
it's like
you know you're in some kind of uh you
know highly tense dog
fight with another plane and um it's
like can you react quickly
if you can reduce the reaction time by
100 by a tenth of a second
um you're you know that that's a big
deal and so there were experiments done
with
you know fighter pilots and so on where
where they're like
measuring their brain waves and such
like to try and do that
of course it's a little bit tricky
because the question of
you know did you really mean to press
that button to fire that missile
well it's one thing to get to the point
where you really decide you're going to
do it and you move your finger
and you press the button it's another to
say let's record that
that slight beginnings of a thought
somewhere in your brain
that might turn into you deciding to
press the button now of course
it could be the case that even recording
the beginnings of the thought it's like
okay
let's power up that particular piece of
equipment so that it's ready
if in fact the person decides a tenth of
a second later
yes they really meant that go ahead and
press that button then it sort of
you know it's primed to be ready to do
its thing but anyway it's been sort of a
long-running story will you be able to
type by thought
um i had always bought when i was a kid
i always thought you got to attach all
those icky electrodes with all that
weird jelly stuff
to your head and it's it's like you know
if your hair falls out it's easier to do
that turns out it isn't actually
difficult to attach those
even when you've got uh you know all
your healthy um
you know head of hair so to speak so it
wasn't really a a big feature there
but it's it's still we're still not
there yet the type by thought thing is
still not there
it's certainly of interest to people who
uh you know are paralyzed in some way
um who who can't uh then it becomes very
interesting to pick up those
those nerve impulses because that's then
you can kind of you know move a cursor
around on a screen
things like that just by thought without
having to actually move an arm if you
can't move your arm
um and and similarly you know being able
to pick up signals not from the brain
but from the spinal cord
and being able to use that to move legs
and things like that without having to
actually use the
if the if the nerves if you don't have
working nerves that let you do that
yourself
having connecting that to electronics is
a good thing and one of the things
that's happened more recently is using
machine learning
to say okay we've got this array
of that we're able to pick up data from
a bunch of nerve cells what does that
mean
does that particular pattern of
excitation of these particular nerves
does that mean you're trying to move the
cursor to the left
well you've either either you've got to
learn
how to produce the right pattern of
electrical stimulation electrical
effects in your brain
to do that or something that's got to
learn from you what you meant
by that and kind of a a sort of
symbiosis of those two things a merger
of those things is probably the most
likely to work i mean
after all when we learn you know how to
move our fingers to type or something
we are learning what is it what is this
pattern of electrical stimulation in our
brain
that causes us to type the word th e or
something like this
that's what we're learning we're
learning how to do that and and the fact
that that's learning how we actually
produce electrical signals that move our
actual fingers
we could as well um have uh be doing
that
to uh to move some piece of electronics
that's connected to us that's sort of an
application for kind of the neuroscience
uh ideas
there's also the question of can we feed
data into our brain
could we have something where you know
you don't have to
actually look at that text message
that's coming in
it could be just directly played into
your brain um or you could have
something where
you are uh you're um
uh you know you don't even have to go
typing on a computer
i want to know this you don't have to
ask well now for some question
it's kind of just built in and it's as
if it's in your own personal memory
well the fact is the the uh for example
with our
eyes the rate at which we can get data
into our brains
through our eyes is really very good i
mean it's it's some
you know well it's at least
what is it up a 100 megabytes per second
or something
um is the is the kind of on that order
it's it's a lot of data that we're
getting in
from just seeing things through our eyes
so
it's going to be it's a lot of effort of
electronics to make that thing that's
sort of an array of electrodes that will
somehow inject that kind of data into
your brain
now for example if your eyes aren't
functioning
then being able to inject that data
directly into the visual cortex of the
back of our heads
where where the data goes from our eyes
that can be useful to do that
electronically
but as a way of sort of getting a higher
bandwidth communication channel
with the world i think that's a that's a
challenging thing to achieve there
of course you know the ultimate thing
one one thinks about
is to what extent can we outsource the
activities of our brain
to say oh i don't want to do that piece
of arithmetic myself
i'll just get my the machine that's
connected to my brain to do it so
somebody asks you
you know what's seven times eight and
it's like instead of remembering that in
your own brain
it's being remembered or computed in
this
sort of ancillary brain that is a
computer connected to your brain
and maybe that happens in a way where
you don't even realize that it's not
in your brain that that computation is
going on to you it feels like
i just know the answer it's connected to
my brain
is that going to be something that's
going to work um potentially yes at some
point in the future
i think it will be an interesting
feeling but the thing to realize is
outsourcing things to machines is
something we're in a very good position
to do right now i mean in my
life i've spent lots of effort building
our
full-scale computational language our
wolfram language system
whose main objective is to be able to
take the things that we think about
be able to let us communicate by sort of
typing them into a computer
and then outsource the computation that
has to be done
or the finding that knowledge to
and or computing that knowledge to the
computer
and then using our eyes to bring it back
and and for me for example particularly
i tend to
store a lot of a lot of information
about my life a lot of sort of personal
analytics data i have you know
every piece of email i've i've sent and
received for the last 30 something years
and
you know most of the keystrokes i've
typed for for a very large number of
years and all kinds of other data like
that
and so for me i'm in a sense outsourcing
my human memory to my machine and when i
want to know oh i have
have i thought about that before well i
you know i
can use my own human memory to try and
remember that
but also i i have a decent human memory
i think
but um uh that but also i've got this
outsourced memory
in my computer that allows me to just
sort of supercharge what i can actually
remember for myself
so i think that that sort of symbiosis
is something that can already easily
happen
by virtue of having the right tools to
interact with computers without
having something that's sort of directly
attached to the brain
okay well let's see um
oh actually this is a good question from
nick here what techniques do i use to
to remember information when studying
all these all these kinds of fields that
i
that i study i don't think i have any
systematic technique for remembering
things i think any time
i kind of think to myself i'm going to
memorize this thing
um you know i guess when i was a kid i
did that a bit and
and you know it turned out to just have
a pretty good memory so
all these tricks for let me remember
this let me come up with a mnemonic
didn't
really add up to much um
the uh the main way to understand things
is to know everything around them so to
speak and to also
have a the way to remember things is to
actually understand them deeply enough
that you can kind of reconstruct what
there is
from kind of fragments so to speak that
you
understand why it works that way so it
isn't just a random fact
this or that but it somehow fits into
this pattern
that allows you to kind of reconstruct
recover that fact
just from sort of the engram of things
around it without having to say oh yeah
i remember that specific
thing um you know i think that as i've
learned more different fields
you know i see many many parallels and
correspondences
and how this is just like this thing i
learned over here
i mean there's there's lots of knowledge
in the world but there's also
lots of patterns of how that knowledge
works and there's lots that are shared
between different fields
and kind of learning those patterns by
learning any field deeply enough and
then saying
hey wait a minute haven't i seen that
kind of thing before um you know this
comes from this is just like what
happens in this place that to me is sort
of the best way to remember things
and as i say having a deep enough
knowledge of how things work
that even if you forget a piece over
here it's easy to fill that in because
you know what the big picture
of how it's all generated is
let's see another question here
from um uh
from nick do i have opinions about why
mars one
failed i didn't know they'd actually
definitively failed
okay so it was an effort
slightly bizarre effort for people to
take
a one-way trip to mars to become
colonists of the planet mars um
you know i think it's a certain kind of
person that says
hey you know i'm okay just going off to
this place where i'm never going to come
back from
obviously in human history that's
happened plenty of times
people have gone off to colonize a new
world of some kind
and without a serious expectation that
they're going to go back
and that's something that's happened i'm
not sure that in today's world with all
of the expectations of communication and
travel and so on
that that's as attractive an opportunity
but um
i think the primary thing if you want to
colonize mars the first thing you have
to do is get to mars
and then you have to prove that you can
actually have
a self-sustaining colony you know i
think that there was the experiment of
you know the biosphere 2 experiment for
example
of trying to have this this closed
ecosystem
that now ends up as this sort of
monument to that in
near tucson arizona um that uh
was sort of an effort to put a bunch of
plants and some people and things
into the sort of sealed dome and just
say okay
pretend you're on mars how does it work
out and there were lots of problems in
getting that to work out so it's sort of
a little bit of an unsolved problem
how you make a an earth-like ecosystem
that is a separate small sort of
earth-like ecosystem
you know we have the whole earth to uh
for our ecosystem to play out in with
lots of big trees and
oceans and and uh uh you know
air currents and all kinds of things if
you're doing that in a little dome
on mars where the atmosphere is vastly
thinner than it is on earth
um it's a it's a different story of
course then we get into questions like
can we terraform mars or venus for that
matter
can we turn those planets into something
where
you have something like an atmosphere
similar to the earth i mean there's sort
of a theory
i have no idea whether it's really
correct that if you
blow up the ice caps of mars which have
lots of water in them
they have lots of of ice in them um if
you if you blow them up with with enough
nuclear explosions and so on
you can throw enough water vapor up into
the atmosphere of mars
that you can potentially make something
that's more like an earth-like
atmosphere i'm not sure if that's really
a true theory
there's also been a persistent theory
for decades that on venus
you know mars is a very thin atmosphere
venus has a pretty thick atmosphere
and it's very very hot on the surface
you know spacecraft
that land on the surface of venus have
survived for at most like 15 minutes
before just
like basically melting um so the
the question of venus is can you sort of
make the atmosphere thinner
and so there are theories about uh you
know seeding bacteria in the clouds of
venus
to try and um uh make it so that it will
that will change the atmosphere of venus
and um uh and make it a an earth-like
livable planet
we have to then ask i mean there's a
certain question of sort of
uh ultimate planetary environmentalism
so to speak
um and uh sort of a it's a complicated
planetary ethics question i suppose
um you know do you say okay it's fine
venus is the way it is right now uh you
know
let's just make it earth-like because
that's what we want to do and you know
maybe that's a good thing to do
um but there are obviously uh lots of
complicated um
arguments to be had about well what if
there was a form of life that existed on
venus in it we don't really know how to
detect
it yet but in 50 years we'll understand
what it is and then we'll be like oh my
gosh
we just destroyed all of that does that
matter does it not matter
it's like we have a virus that's been
attacking us for the past year and a bit
you know we would like to make it
extinct you know we have to ask
ourselves is that um
uh you know i think i think most people
would agree that's a pretty good deal
for humans to make that virus extinct
you know how does that compare to the
the creatures of venus if there are any
probably microorganisms if there were
anything which
there probably aren't um not life in the
form that we are used to life on earth
well let's see maybe one or two more
questions and then um
let's see
oh boy somebody asked the question why
does the universe exist which i have
been working on i
i wrote a piece about that i'm not going
to dive into that here maybe another
time
that is not a five minute answer
um
let's see
um
well there's a couple here which i can
answer somewhat quickly there's one from
coin asking gravity is a force that
pulls things in
not a force that pushes things dark
matter which is the sort of mysterious
uh matter in the universe that is a
force that's pulling things
we don't know what it is that's pulling
could that be somehow
uh the result its effects be like a
shielding of this sort of um
uh oh i see some something where there's
sort of a
a a pushing force as well as a pulling
force associated with gravity
actually that's exactly what dark energy
is supposed to be
ordinary gravity pulls things together
the formulas for that describe
gravity and that we actually we can
reproduce in our model of physics
um are say if you have a lump of mass
if you have this thing that has a mass
it will exert a gravity and that gravity
will pull things in
but if that mass was negative if it was
you know usually
you have a thing it has a a certain
weight it's it's it's being pulled by
gravity
but if the mass was negative it would be
the gravity it produces and the way that
it will be pulled by gravity would be
the opposite
and it would be repelled by gravity it
would push things away
so so there is sort of an idea that
there can be negative mass
stuff which is dark energy in our models
of physics
there is sort of the equivalent of that
because in a sense throughout
space there's a certain amount of
activity
which is necessary to kind of knit
together the structure of space
and that activity an excess of that
activity is what leads to the presence
of energy or mass
and so if there's less than usual
activity
in space it leads to the equivalent of
negative mass and so on
um let's see
there was a question here from riff if
time stops in a black hole does that
mean all matter
in a black hole stops aging yes
i mean what happens in a black hole in
an ordinary in the simplest kind of
black hole
that isn't spinning around is at the
center of the black hole
there's a singularity in space-time that
has the feature that
time just stops it's as if
so what is that like for a thing that is
experiencing that
well there are big gravitational forces
so the thing might be torn apart but if
you can
if you can ignore that and just say what
does it feel
as it's going to this space like
singularities it's called
this place where time just stops what
does it feel like to have
time stop well it's like imagine you
were an ai
and you were operating on a computer and
somebody switches off the computer
time is stopping for you but the the
things are going on in the outside world
but for you time has just stopped
no time passes and so you don't get to
ponder the fact that
oh this is very nice i'm not aging
anymore
because time has stopped you don't get
to do anything
no thoughts occur so if for the
it's it's like you're just frozen and
and
there is there is nothing uh it's it's
like
time is not passing time has stopped you
don't get to ponder
the fact that gosh i'm so lucky i've
stopped aging
time has stopped because nothing you
don't get to think about that so to
speak
now from the outside world yes
it can look to be from the outside world
it's like gosh
that thing is very lucky it's not aging
anymore time is not passing for that
thing
that's what happens even at the the
outside of the event horizon of a black
hole
things that um to somebody far away from
the black hole
it looks as if that thing that clock
that was going and you see the clock
ticking ticking ticking
as it gets close to the event horizon of
a black hole it will stop ticking it
will just become
frozen there its time will be frozen its
position will be frozen
if you were in the clock the clock has a
different perception of time
and for the clock it's just falling
through this event horizon and
continuing going tick tock tick tock
until it gets to the singularity in the
black hole
at which point it just stops but it
can't
detect that it's stopped because
everything that it might use to detect
what's happening
has also stopped
let's see well
um
maybe one or two more here gosh there's
there's a lot
of interesting questions here
um
all right there's one here
i'll do two more
okay there's one from markup
why do we need to super cool materials
for superconductors or quantum systems
why can't we drive them mechanically at
a set frequency to cool them
preferentially in one direction
okay what does it mean what is
temperature
temperature when we make something
hotter
what's happening is we're making all the
molecules in that
thing whizz around faster so when we
cool things down
the molecules are going slower and
slower and slower there's a direct
relationship between temperature
and the speed that those molecules are
going at so
often those molecules will have forces
between them
and those forces will sometimes be so
strong that they don't allow the
molecules to whizz around much
and that's when you get a solid and
things like this so
the question is how do you cool stuff
down
and the the most common ways to cool
things down
have to do with the fact that when you
have
okay so so what's making those molecules
whizz around is energy
and what you're doing is when you cool
things down a very common thing is to
say
let's keep the same amount of energy in
this
box of gas but let's somehow have that
energy be distributed in such a way
that every molecule gets less of it and
so that that means that the
the amount the amount of energy
associated with the motion of those
molecules will go down
and so there are a whole variety of
techniques for cooling things down in
the end you have to use another effect
as well
which is um you tend to have to use the
effect
that molecules tend to attract each
other and so
as you uh you can kind of trade off
energy of motion
for energy that's associated with the
attraction between molecules
and that's a standard technique that is
used when you
are cooling down um something like let's
say cooling down air to make it
eventually liquid
um that you're using that um uh that
effect
of of the fact that there's a force of
attraction between molecules
you're kind of using that to slow down
the molecules
to make them effectively have a lower
temperature but you're also using
in many cases just the pure process of
expanding gases
cooling them down the gas laws say
pressure times volume
equals a constant times temperature and
so by changing pressure and volume
you can change temperature and so on but
there's
there's other techniques um
for making things very cold there's a
technique that's used to reach
down to uh so so when you make something
colder
eventually it's as cold as it can be
because
temperature is the rate at which all
these molecules are whizzing around
but eventually when you make it cold
enough that corresponds to the molecules
effectively having stopped
because of effects in quantum mechanics
there are zero point fluctuations
they don't actually stop but they in a
sense get as slow as they can ever get
and that's and the the temperature at
which they get as slow as they can ever
get is what's called absolute zero
minus 273 273.16 etc
degrees centigrade that's the
temperature at which
kind of there's no more you you've made
everything as cold as it can be
now as you reach down to uh that
temperature is also
called zero kelvins um that's the that's
the other
and so then our ordinary room
temperature would be
you know 293 kelvins um or 20 degrees
centigrade or whatever
um the so at zero kelvins
one talks about cooling things down to
millikelvins
or micro kelvins that's with a
thousandth or a millionth
of um the uh of degrees centigrade of
absolute zero
and there are techniques that get used
in that end part of cooling there's a
thing called
um uh adiabatic demagnetization
um and those techniques kind of mess
around with
the the detailed alignment of atoms and
the detailed way that
atomic spins line up and so on and so
when you're asking about
cooling things down by sort of uh
sending everything to go in one
direction
those are kinds of techniques that are a
little bit closer to what's done
when you're cooling things very very
close to absolute zero
um and uh the the sort of the question
of
of you know in a sense how would you
cool things down well one way to cool
things down
would be to have a very molecular scale
computer
let's say and to have it be the case
that it's
you know it's in this box of gas every
time it seems a gas molecule it's going
fast it says oh you're going above the
speed limit
i'm going to stop you or i'm going to
turn you you know do so
tweak you in some way and gradually sort
of molecule by molecule
slow the molecules down maybe you're
going to say you're going too fast in
that direction let me
let me tweak you a little bit so that
you're going to collide with another
molecule that's going fast in the other
direction then you're both
you'll both maybe bounce off at a
slightly slower speed or something like
this
you know doing the molecule by molecule
cooling down of of the system
that kind of technique sometimes called
maxwell's demon
is kind of a way of doing that sort of
molecular scale cooling down
it's thought of as kind of a thought
experiment not as something you can
actually do
and as a matter of fact some of the
reasons that
that gases work the way they do is
because
we're not doing things like that if we
did things like that and that was
routinely happening
we would see gases behave in different
ways than they normally behave
but that's sort of where you can imagine
if you could construct such a system
with fine enough
computational and and uh sensors and
actuators and so on
you could cool a gas down by doing that
kind of molecule by molecule
uh kind of kind of work okay final
question for today
varun asks what's the difference between
science and technology
and how do they complement each other
this is one of these i think that's an
easy question but
now i'm going to realize that i'm
descending into a
a giant rabbit hole really
the story of science is it's about
understanding the world as the world is
the story of technology is taking the
world
as it is and essentially tweaking it
or identifying pieces of it that we can
use to achieve particular human purposes
so when we say what's a kind of
scientific understanding
of i don't know uh the flow of a fluid
the flow of water
that's all about can we if we see water
flowing in this way
can we understand what it's doing can we
predict what it's going to do things
like this
that's the role of science the role of
technology
is given that we have water flow when we
know certain things about how it works
if we put paddles in the water in this
way in that way what consequence will
that have
will allow that allow us to make a uh
you know a mill or something that that a
water mill
um or something like this from the water
in other words can we take
that that that thing that exists in the
physical world
and can we apply it for our particular
purposes to achieve our particular ends
and sometimes when we do technology we
don't need to understand how the system
works
we just say yup we've got the technology
that if um water flows quickly in this
direction we can use it to
to turn this wheel that we can use to
grind wheat or something
and um uh that then and that's enough we
don't need to know how the water flow
works we just need to know that we can
kind of
insert ourselves into that to make
something that is technologically useful
whereas in science it's like well how
does that work can we explain
can we describe can we kind of tell a
story about how the water is operating
um even if what we learn is that well
the water does all these complicated
things we don't know why we care
in the sense that it's very interesting
and intellectually
worth knowing but it isn't something
where we can say well given that we know
it works this way
we can then immediately use it for some
human purpose
now it's a it's a big trade-off for
example in the world of machine learning
where we have all of these different
techniques that say
we can identify that was you know we can
recognize
this is a kind of cell that's going to
do this and that's one that's going to
do this
and we can do it just by looking at the
microscopic pictures of the cells
and just saying there's all these
features of these microscopic pictures
and this machine learning system
is going to pick out the ones it needs
to say is the cell going to do this or
that
but that isn't science in a sense
because in a sense
what that's doing is we don't really
know how that works there's no narrative
about how that works
it's just what we feed it into this
machine learning system and it just
figures out oh it works this way rather
than that way
much as we as humans might have learned
oh that thing is going to do this that
thing is going to do that
without being able to tell a more
detailed story a more detailed
scientific story about what's going on
now often there's sort of a feedback
loop between these things because
yes we can just uh use the machine
learning system we don't really know how
it works but it's going to distinguish
this cell from that cell
but then we can leverage that we can
build on that to do something that is
more scientific
in the sense it's more sort of telling a
story about what's going to happen
now one place where technology uh
sometimes one
the sort of mixed situations like for
example if you look at programs
most of the time we're writing programs
explicitly we write
every line of computational language
every line of code
we're just writing that um and uh
we're not um doing something where um
the um where so we're constructing
something for our particular human
purpose
one of the things that has been
something i've been very involved in
um is kind of just searching the
computational universe of possible
programs
just as we look around the world to sort
of scientifically identify
oh there's this magnetic material that's
cool it works this way
and then we can ingest that as something
we use for technology
we make these things that use magnetism
to work
doing the same kind of thing for the
computational universe understanding
enough of the science of what's out
there in the computational universe
that we can see what things to pull in
for the purpose of making technology
so that's that's a few thoughts on the
sort of difference between science and
technology
an interesting question is whether
they're both sort of endless frontiers
is there an infinite number of things
that can be invented i think it's very
easy to see that the answer to that is
going to be yes
there are an infinite number of things
that can be invented the only question
is whether you care about every one of
those inventions
what defines what inventions we care
about in terms of science are there an
infinite number of things
that can potentially be explained my
guess is the answer is yes
but that's a slightly less obvious
question and it relies on
this phenomenon of computational
reducibility and pockets of
computational reducibility
things which i've understood in the
context of my
kind of science of the computational
universe and more recently
understanding fundamental physics i've
understood more about the sense in which
there can be
sort of an infinite number of possible
different types of understanding that
you can have of the universe
and in that sense science is inevitably
an endless frontier as technology is an
endless frontier of all the different
things that one can
invent that can operate in our universe
all right well i think i should wrap up
here for now um and
uh thanks for joining us uh see you
another time